um can India become a superpower I think
yes shortens it is I think it has all
the all the ingredients is the raw
ingredients to become a superpower but
it happens can use already the ski
activate miss the size the size the
geographic size as well as the growth
economic load is how Cece is so I again
we need immediately pointers for my
monster is far it has the culture that
very well which also has potential to
have good impact I am the world what
they missing but this the correct ideas
based on us so you for earlier once
economic found this place he's super
super oxide that is a cultural as well
as Venus installed because all your
ingredients we copy Thomas but now we're
30 40 years or even less but the world
would like to see India some say how is
that will I face refuse verification
every prophet living last